this video is sponsored by research hub
now this is a monster of a video not
because it is scary but because it is a
thing of extraordinary or daunting size
and well a lot and a lot of research and
review articles have come out this year
which has certainly kept me busy
and much of which until i made this
video i completely forgot about
so i thought it would be useful to
revisit some of the biggest longevity
breakthroughs from this year all into
one video as a helpful guide
i've used timestamps to break the video
down into useful sections
and i'll make a playlist of all the
relevant full-length videos mentioned as
obviously i won't have as much time to
cover all the details here
firstly we'll look at research that has
improved our understanding of the aging
process
then we'll look at advances in cellular
reprogramming we'll then look at
senescent cells and synolytics and
lastly cover supplements and diets so
without further ado here are this year's
longevity breakthroughs
so firstly we got some more insight into
understanding the aging process
and speaking of aging pathways we learnt
more about the sertuments this year a
family of proteins that use the
metabolites nad plus to remove acell
tags from proteins
in particular i did a deep dive on so 2
and 6.
overexpression of this protein in one
particular mouse train extended lifespan
in both males and females and it reduced
frailty
so 2 and 6 is found in the nucleus and
activities are mainly linked to dna
repair
but how exactly it promotes longevity is
still unclear
there has also been some advances in
aging clocks this year
these are biological markers that can be
used to predict one's chronological age
sometimes can be referred to as your
biological age as it is a more accurate
prediction of your health status than
age alone
one you're most familiar with is the
epigenetic lock which uses dna
methylation
we'll come back to this later and there
has been some advances in predicting age
with even less data input though we
haven't read these studies yet
whoops
but a study i did read developed a
different clock that is called i age
an inflammatory agent clock that is
based off protein abundance in blood of
individuals aged between 1896
unlike epigenetic clocks i age
identified a factor that is part of the
clock that may also be functionally
associated with aging
the protein cxtl9 which is also involved
in cardiac aging
and speaking of cardiac aging
cardiovascular disease is a common
age-associated disease and a reduction
in microfascular density and arterial
stiffening also occurs of age
this year there was a publication that
explored whether fed f
a protein that gets secreted from cells
and promotes the growth of new arteries
could help
well mice treated with fed f lived
longer and had an extended health span
including features such as reduced
muscle loss reduced abdominal fat
accumulation and reduce bone loss to
name a few the mouth strain don't live
as long as other my strains
so it will be important to see how
reproducible this work is but i'm pretty
certain we will hear more about fedjaf
next year so don't forget it so how much
of aging is genetic
well previous work puts estimates on the
heritability of aging from 20 to 30
percent mainly from twin studies
to 48
and 33
in men and women respectively if it's a
family with a centenarian
but it's also thought that these may be
overestimates with heritability of
longevity being closer to 16
or even below 10 percent
heritability is the ratio of the genetic
component to the sum of the genetic and
environmental factors
now there is no right or wrong answer to
the heritability of human lifespan
simply because heritability seems to be
specific to a population and the
environmental exposure current in that
population
the interesting question is then to know
whether any and what regions of the
genome we have on our cells is
associated with longevity
well a study came out this year and
they've identified some rare genetic
coding variants from a cohort of 515
ashkenazi jewish centenarians
by having a cohort of similar
descendants it helped to homogenize the
genetic background making it hopefully
easier to detect any causal genetic
variants linked to longevity
so what do they see
well they sort of further confirmed what
is seen in other model organisms such
that there is a longevity association in
the insulin and ampk signaling pathways
but interestingly they also found
pathways linked to human aging that have
not been identified in multiple
organisms such as the predictive effects
of rare variants in wind signaling on
human lifespan
now a topic that isn't formally a
hallmark of aging that i nonetheless
think should be is the gut microbiome
and how it gets perturbed with age
our gut microbiomes play various roles
within the body from aiding with food
digestion to shaping our immune response
this biosis has also been linked with
type 2 diabetes and obesity
one way to modulate one's gut microbiome
is through the lovely process of fecal
microbiota
i'll spare the details but in this
publication from this year they
performed this microbiota transplant
from young mice to old mice and saw
restoration of many markers of brain
health such as a reduction in microglia
size which suggests that they are less
inflamed and this was correlated with
improved spatial memory performance
tests
a topic that is a hallmark of aging that
got some extra insight this year was
loss of proteosis
how proteins get misfolded or aggregated
with age
proteins need to be correctly folded to
perform their function
misfolding can also happen due to the
incorrect amino acids the building
blocks of proteins getting inserted
this was elaborated on in this study
here where they found that if you slow
down the process of protein synthesis
translation it improves the fidelity of
protein production and this increased
the lifespan of yeast worms and flies
translating pun intended to humans may
be a challenge but i think this was a
cool study
and speaking of cool studies a study
came out this year where they used
partial cellular reprogramming in the
heart of mice
the heart loses regenerative potential
with age and tends to fix damage by
patching up with fibrotic scars instead
of generating new cells
here by controlling the expression of
yamanaka factors and cardiomyocytes same
heart cells
so that it caused partial but not
complete reprogramming it got the
cardiomyocytes to replicate and reduced
the amount of heart function lost after
myocardial infarction
and so celluloid reprogramming is the
process of going from one cell type to
another
commonly it is used in the context of
describing how a differentiated cell
like a heart cell can be converted into
a stem cell an undifferentiated cell
that has the potential to keep
replicating and also to become many
different cell types
as you might imagine this is really
interesting technology and so it may not
surprise you to hear that there are many
companies pursuing this further which
down the line could lead to regenerative
therapies to treat aging
indeed this year has led to the
announcement of many more companies
joining the space
this includes altos labs reported to be
backed by billionaires yuri milner and
jeff bezos and include scientists in the
reprogramming space such as manuel
serrano will freak and steve horvath
then more recently brian armstrong ceo
of coinbase announced the company new
limit that he is helping to create with
blake buyers hoping to extend human
health span
i was very fortunate to be able to speak
to brian about this announcement and
they're currently in the recruiting
stage so as of yet it's unclear who's
going to be part of the team
so exciting times
now this brings me on to senescent cells
and to me it feels like loads of
research has come out this year
regarding senescent cells but this is
also my research speciality
so maybe it's what i read most and just
survivorship bias but there has been a
lot of cool research nonetheless
there's also been some recent research
out of our lab but i'll release a video
on that shortly senescent cells
accumulate with age and are thought to
even drive aspects of aging
which is fitting given the evidence that
removing senescent cells has benefits in
old mice
here using a genetic tool they remove
senescent cells based on the marker p16
but p16 doesn't mark all not only
senescent cells senescent cells are
heterogeneous there is no one type so
interestingly a study came up this year
where they identified senescent cells
expressing a different marker p21
here removing p21 positive cells
intermittently improved physical
function in 23 month old mice
and so again this supports the clearance
of senescent cells that accumulate with
age being beneficial
selective removal of senescent cells are
called psenolytics
however these experiments i've just
shown you are using a genetic approach
but there are also other ways to clear
senescent cells with more approaches
identified this year
one of a more long-term out-of-the-box
thinking involves being able to activate
our immune systems to actually clear the
senescent cells this strategy seems
promising based on the demonstration
that accelerated aging of the immune
system
achieved in the smell study by enhancing
dna damage
resulted in the accumulation of
senescent cells
rapamycin was given to this mouse model
and that reduced markers of senescence
in immune cells
so it suggests at least the involvement
of the immune system in detecting and
clearing senescent cells
and it suggests finding ways to activate
the immune response or prevent immune
decline during aging may be ways to
support senescent cell clearance using
our endogenous system
but this year we've also seen further
development beyond the conventional
approach
namely we looked at an antibody drug
conjugate approach and a vaccine-based
approach
these target senescent cells by binding
to proteins expressed on the surface the
hope is that these approaches could be
more specific to senescent cells and may
minimize any impact on healthy cells
at the moment both these approaches are
kind of proof of principle and so i
think it's far more likely we will see
the adoption of synolytics first to a
wider audience
speaking of which this year led to the
publication of a news analytic
discovered in grape seed extract pretty
prosonaiden c1 which when given
intermittently to old mice extended
their lifespan as you can see here
it will be interesting to see this
followed up in human clinical trials
now this last study technically also
falls under the category supplement and
diet which we'll cover now
so diet then
so 2021 has brought many new insights
but things still seem a little bit
unclear and i made a summary video on
this that was covering a review article
that's basically looked at all of the
current mouse data to see how the
different diets compared to each other
and to me one of the clear take-homes is
the fact that it's likely to be very
dependent on the individual in question
however a study that i presented at the
beginning of the year showed that
restriction of dietary branch-chain
amino acids so leucine isoleucine and
phthaline in wild-type mice starting at
midlife extended the lifespan of males
but not the females
in terms of supplements it's worth
mentioning the announcement of the
rapamycin pearl trial that is underway
to test rapamycin in 200 participants
over 12 months at different doses
that will evaluate different blood tests
body compositions
fecal microbiome testing immune and
inflammation health tests as well as the
methylation age clock and skeletal
muscle tests
and i also caught up with dr brad
stanfield this year who's also in the
works of conducting a trial using
wepomycin we also got the first data
from a small human clinical trial on
alpha-ketoglutarate supplementation
where based on an epigenetic biological
age estimate they saw an average a
decline in biological age of eight years
after an average seven months of use
in this video i made some important
points regarding how much we can take
from the study but there are other
larger trials in the works looking at
more measurements
so i'll let you know that data as soon
as it comes out
and this trial is being coordinated in
part by professor brian kennedy who very
kindly came onto the channel this year
for an interview and on that note i also
want to give a shout out to all my
interviewees this year this was new to
me and i really enjoyed doing them and i
hope they complement the more in-depth
analyses that i like to do
now i haven't covered everything in this
video
in terms of longevity news this year so
let me know what i've missed and what
are your longevity highlights for the
year and with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this video research hub
research hub is a platform where
researchers can upload articles
summarize and discuss the findings and
reward for researchcoin
the overall aim is to accelerate the
pace of scientific research and to make
it more accessible
i've already been using the sites and
have uploaded the papers relevant to
this video find the link to research hub
in the description
so with that happy new year thank you to
my patreon supporters and thank you for
listening